So, we know how to create and
read from our database entries, but
how do we update existing
data within our database?
It seems we have a situation on
our hands that calls for this.
Veggie burgers across town
have been all the rage,
causing rapid price competition
amongst our restaurants.
Urban Burger wants to cut the price
of their veggie burger to $2.99.
With SQLAlchemy, performing an update
like this is a pretty simple,
four-step process.
First, we execute a query to find
the veggie burger we want and
store it in a variable.
Second, we declare the new
price of the variable.
Next, we add the variable
to our session.
And, finally,
we commit the session to the database.
Follow along as I do this
from the Python shell.
So, the first step in our update
process is to find the exact item we
want to update.
Looking at the SQLAlchemy documentation
for queries, I see we have a filter_by
feature that let's us filter queries
based on attribute entries, like name.
Let's go to our Python shell and
give it a try.
So, let's use the filter_by function
to find all the veggie burgers in
our restaurant menu database.
Following the syntax
from the documentation,
I append .filter_by to my
query on MenuItems and
set the Veggie Burger as the name of
the menu item I want to search for.
Then, I store it in the variable
named veggieBurgers.
The filter_by function always
returns a collection of objects.
So, let's create a for
loop to iterate over each object and
retrieve the information about
each of these veggie burgers.
Inside our for loop, let's print
out the ID of each veggie burger,
its current price, and
the restaurant it belongs to.
I'm also going to print a new line
character to make our results a little
bit easier to read.
When I close my for
loop in execute, I get back a list of
all the veggie burgers in my database.
The first one here is from
Urban Burger and has an ID of eight.
Now, I will create another query where
I only return the menu item with
an ID of eight.
I will store it as UrbanVeggieBurger.
If I append the .one function
to the end of my query,
I make sure SQLalchemy only
gives me the one object I want,
instead of a list that I
would have it iterate over.
Just to double check we have
the right burger, let me go ahead and
check its price.
Yep, the veggie burger costs $5.99,
just like it did in our first query.
Now, let's reset the price of
the Urban Veggie Burger to $2.99.
We can then add the UrbanVeggieBurger
object to our session and
commit it to the database.
So now, if we execute the same original
query to see all the veggie burgers in
our database, we see that Urban Burger's
veggie burger now has a price of $2.99.
Now, let's assume all the other
restaurants have reacted to
Urban Burger's audacious price drop and
want to set their burger
prices to $2.99 as well.
Let's use our same for loop and
modify it a bit to change the price of
all the veggie burgers in
our database to $2.99.
I'm going to use this if statement to
avoid unnecessary database updates to
an entry that already
has a price of $2.99,
and just update the other
veggie burger menu items.
Now, querying a third time,
I see all the veggie burgers in
our menu have the same price.
Let's get a little more practice with
updates by answering the following
quiz questions.